welcome to this video a 15 minute game
again playing rookie hm I guess that's
how it's meant and I'm not sure about
this flag is that something in the
Caribbean maybe Puerto Rico yeah okay
not so far let's see um a ruin and again
I get this get this line to play this
guy before I don't think so and in the
end of the game i have played Knight c3
no none let's play it in a more
conventional fashion this time well not
like Knight c3 or something weird I mean
I'm what I'm thinking about is just to
go see 3d for like you normally play in
there in the room
b5 and D success the way this is played
let's see if he is some if he knows this
oh of course you can also find this find
this yourself it's not rocket science b5
and b6 this is in fact a pretty
interesting line of like to unbalance
the game of it get it out of them very
well trodden path of their main lines
this some position after b5 and b6 has
been reached a number of times by our
own yarn even so it's something to ya to
take serious mm okay d 5 mm yeah this is
interesting I don't like d5 let's start
with that I don't like a five this
doesn't make much sense to me it gives
up a good square on a five what another
matter is maybe to take I guess night
x95 even that is not clear hmm
hmm I'm not easy maybe take admission g5
just to develop I'd like to get a fluid
development him I mean taking on c6 up
there then probably even was light takes
c6 but here this is not so easy now what
should he do he can easily run into pins
maybe night Queen d6 but then i can
think of taking at Bishop b3 very active
pieces Queen d6 there also is 94 and
hard same what sound puts better ok yeah
maybe can also take on c3 yeah but rock
D&I Bishop the 891 Bishop c7 at least
yeah he's doing that Bishop the eighth
wait wait oh if I take yeah I'm just a
piece down Bishop dignity one or not mmm
I'm just a piece down nonsense i must
absolutely must recapture sometimes do
you really feel like your brain that
what the heck just of course just 10 to
1 c 3 yeah quindi five runs right into
this visual move this is a bit
questionable I would say yeah but maybe
you can go yeah exactly maybe can go
here and let's see
yeah I wonder what's the best here it's
not that's so clear you he wants to play
Bishop g4 and set up the spin if I go
Bishop dito Bishop to Bishop g4 best
idea bishop every Queen f3 night XD form
that's not not very comfortable yeah
Bishop g4 so slight problem really and
of course c3 hang so I need to address
this sound as well okay let's consider
more aggressive approaches what about d
D 5 D 595 yeah maybe
okay not not one hundred percent sure
about this but I don't want to play slow
movement maybe giveaway possible
initiative 95 I guess he must play
theoretically speaking now we cannot go
up the eighth of course so 95 you must
do that there is no other square simply
and after that I'm going to take Bishop
takes and then it's interesting I was
thinking about Bishop e7 AB should be
seven has an additional idea of this
should be formed yeah that's not bad
there should be something
yeah yeah goodness okay so is he
thinking about something else instead of
ninety-five I cannot really believe in a
move like 98 okay he went for this and
now is it even an idea what if i play
Bishop is seven first maybe it's maybe
even better
I don't see a drawback at least maybe
maybe Bishop g4 hmm maybe Bishop g4
sacrificing an exchange yeah yeah
exchange sex this might might might work
or at least might be a practical try to
make things difficult for white okay is
playing them the symptoms
yeah poor Queen B 6 looks really forced
then 95 Bishop b5 and then what rook e1
or queen f3 to line up against them
maybe line up against of seven
mmm yeah oh this is not really super
convincing you can probably just play
move like you should this happen next
now he's got a five or so long
yeah not not nice at all okay let's
let's build up the pin at least so that
I have some ribbon some tricks based on
this pin if he goes a five I might be
able to use the pin
unfortunately there is no rule that a
queen needs to be taken of sacrificed I
have Queen D foyer guindy for Bishop
takes d4 rook takes the a check King g7
Bishop of a check King back Bishop h6
checkmate but as mentioned there is no
rule that you need to take it would be a
nice rule for me in this particular case
mmm so d6 maybe maybe d6 is not
threatening something I mean it's still
a pin yeah okay I guess it's some one of
those cases where you need to strike
while the iron is hot if I don't do
something now I'm probably losing
anything everything here the problem
with Queen deform was you can just play
Bishop d7 and ignore it and then it's
not clear what the queen is doing or
deform
yeah after the six of course my threat
is just don't--i seven and also that's
the possibility to to play something
like windy five using the Queen in the
center
yeah well if I take yeah maybe you can
just play Bishop see six maybe
but what else yeah I don't see another
move ready but you can probably do that
Bishop c6 what's my move again after
that
I don't really know after Bishop c6 what
should I do it's um he just threatens to
take on c7 neck smooth I don't really
see a good good line and the bishop is
not dead or badly placed on g6 of course
mmm yeah he's taking lots of time
probably a good thing maybe is trying to
find some some even better move when
that fails Bishop c6 is really just good
yeah you really get a wide range of
playing strength in this 15-minute pool
even even he's gotten absolutely super
low rating but I don't know it we played
this quite okay I mean maybe I'm just
doing doing nonsense but still where
exactly is this big mistake in this game
i don't i don't see ended see anything
okay Bishop takes his seven Jeff I don't
really know how to how to how to play
that I mean if I lose the porn I'm a
million not in great shape I wonder if I
should sacrifice only five and play
Queen d6 something like that second they
exchange now there is some merit to that
this is a strong pawn on c7 supported by
the bishop come on let's do that
cackling takes Queen takes is a problem
really Queen d6 Queenie form and then I
don't really know what to reply are no
sorry Queenie 526 is completely Datuk
Queenie one of course hmm but this this
means that if I cannot play Queen d6
this was really bad okay i can i can go
Bishop d6 and I not only can do that i
must do that even but still it's got
queen if for maybe mm-hmm I looks very
shaky okay the other move yeah Wow queen
d6 here or bishop t6 specialty 6
well I guess Bishop t6 down to get it
quickly 23 I can't think when you're
five more stronger okay so at least them
this is seven part is protected from the
moment and g2 a soulful covered h5 I
have aged for at least I mean maybe I
have some other moves but this is at
least a move that's play along
what's my next move really maybe queen
deform if he does not maybe takes on c3
i have twenty-eight probably good i say
probably because after Queen deities of
cotton or is course not forced to take
ok yeah I was really thinking maybe
Queen you form ok but after that you can
I can also recycle fice give it back mmm
yeah yeah but this is something that you
can probably do anyway it's hard to
prevent really ok let's do that Queen
you for if it takes on d4 and then does
not return then maybe I have something f
to bounce them
I came maybe can take n play Bishop d5
it doesn't
hmm if I go maybe maybe here despite the
fact that you can take yeah probably not
probably not working really yeah look T
1 is ok but he can he can give it back
on g3 the the exchange push-up g6 yeah
hy can also give it back okay come on
let's let's play normal move you might
be able to return the exchange but yeah
yes he's doing that but the way to have
queen okay I got queen da checker isn't
this chair this is better check and then
winning the complete rope here
check yeah he's getting is getting this
pawn but nothing to do about it let's
see how to get this done now yeah i
guess the bishop should go to deform
it's really the best possible square
Jack yeah its licensors okay
yeah the the exchange tech debatable I
didn't want to make it so easy if I'm so
I played the six train psych but it
probably is a risky decision check yeah
aged wangs but the main thing is that
I'm protecting F to enter have a good
good control over all here well let's
try that we should g8 a loop t7 trying
to win the h7 porn yeah there's also
Bishop d5 which I can also play yeah
c'mon let's get rid of the bishops take
make it make it easy I will probably win
the queenside using the rook it's not
taking okay
want to keep day to pawn no use to give
it away
yeah again trying for Bishop g8 to win
the h7 pawn yes this time it's a it's a
successful operation I'm down to one
minute I didn't I didn't really look at
the clock probably a reason why he is
still playing this disposition going for
g6 next
I can take F to check it's not not
helping much but ok let's see the
bishops and the rock and there's some
way to meet him check check yeah the
snow the snow is a meeting net check
Bishop t4 at the end check
black resigns yeah he defended really
well first so let's uh let's have a look
at this d 5 is uncommon but free of why
not oh it looks it looks a like a play
will move I was thinking this first yeah
but even that is not clear but then I
was I wasn't even sure if if he may be
can take with this because this is not
so clear yeah in fact i'm probably not
winning material here if I return I
takes that even as the bishops and maybe
I can take with the pawn this is this is
in fact in fact better because this is
hard to get back ok so maybe but ok this
this is certainly not not terrible just
have a good development and here around
here it gets it gets interesting I mean
II five is is in a way of course a
debatable move because it opens up the
g7 bishop and gives him a target on c3
but I was really irritated by a bishop
deform the computer wants to do wants to
play the smooth Jack this I didn't
consider and this is certainly not so
bad for black something like that for
example that's not bad yeah I don't know
if I've probably debatable decision
again maybe this isn't so great I mean
queen f6 I didn't really consider but
even after move like this a no this was
a bad idea my bishops are not doing much
and he's got a very
in position here probably Queenie have
six not bad yeah first this is a very
funny move but it's it's nonsense
because of Bishop d7 this is Jack check
checkmate funny mate but of course after
Queen D for you can just play move like
that and then the queen is just in the
middle of the board for no reason that
needs to do the move I don't really have
a good scribe okay so I went d6 Bishop
d7 yeah this is a good defense is
playing this playing this nicely and
here Jim probably this is not good young
I was I was more concerned about this
smooth I originally thought he can move
the queen but that's Queenie one mate I
probably need to do something like that
and this is comparable to the game and
in some ways but I've lost the sea porn
yeah there is always a bit of
compensation with the pawn like that but
it's probably not sufficient yeah this
is this I don't know
hmm
yeah after that rook to d1 white is
winning even I wasn't sure that I'm
winning but I am what he can do is take
here and take here this is obie should
be five but this is in any case a
possibility that is equal all there is
this move but also interesting i'm not
sure what i'm doing now rook see one
would be one not clear this is what you
could you probably should do it after
that it's already lost as we saw that
this this is this is losing hmm why
Bishop c7 is even better okay I haven't
understood yet why yeah I can understand
a bishop I bishop f7 out so ah the ship
of seven okay yeah I can do that now but
here there is no move and I'm
threatening rook the ATM and this is
devastating okay this is even better I
mean okay this is the winning end game
but the other was even more forceful
okay some people have a good defense ya
think thanks for watching